a test drive in northern Germany this
car may end up sold at auction it's a
1964 ferrari 250 GT lusso one of only
350 worldwide it's estimated to be worth
more than 1 million euros and where cars
like this are sold this woman is not far
behind aneta a Boche an expert on
vintage cars is visiting a client is an
factory lion shaft it's simply the
passion to own something beautiful it's
an unbelievable feeling of joy when the
owner turns the key in the ignition the
engine starts and the 12 cylinders start
purring away it's great lovely fish bath
the Ferrari is carefully inspected
dealers like a bar cheer always involved
in sales in this price category her
address book is full of potential buyers
what they're most interested in other
body and engine any racing past and the
rarity of a vehicle well we really look
for cars that have something exceptional
and this one definitely does only a few
of them were ever built and the body has
a beautiful shape it has a huge
12-cylinder engine there are several
criteria that come together to qualify
this as a very desirable collectors car
uma standards entry SPG alakazam
nephrotic and Swiss tellson Frank pet
Salters owned the car for several years
but is now considering selling it for
financial reasons albeit reluctantly
this is nima just like with music be
remember songs from your past your first
love which you associate with a certain
song and in the same way you associate a
car with certain aspects or phases of
your life bosnians a meta about she
brings together sellers and possible
buyers here in Hamburg at the only
German office of RM Auctions she looks
after collectors from across Europe and
her client base is growing vintage car
prices rose eight percent last year
alone cars are more in demand as
investments than ever before what's in
urine a couple were investing in vintage
cars ten years ago but that was just a
very small group of aficionados it's now
become far more popular and has become a
much broader field what is this I fear
fear bite on his head Cavani a but she
shares the collectors enthusiasm she
regularly takes her jaguar roadster out
for a spin as on this recent jaunt in
the Alps she keeps in touch with clients
and races and rallies because it's
become quite a challenge to find
collectors who want to part with their
vintage babies the SAS Immelman desh
fear that's the tough part of a market
that's so strong we have a lot of
potential customers but there are a few
owners willing to sell they don't see
the point in selling their great cars
because they wouldn't be able to get
anything like it for a similar price
hoodies in pies a moment a feeder and
that's exactly why the auctions are so
successful it's not uncommon to see
proceeds of say seven million euros like
for this pre-war era Mercedes or 1
million for a Porsche once owned by
actor Steve McQueen but there are also
cast for newcomers with prices starting
at fifteen thousand euros for models
like this Fiat 500 or this 1950s Alfa
Romeo
I know all of us it's the excitement
what will happen will that person bid
again or that one will I get it whether
I'm bidding for a client on the phone or
the client is in the auction hall that
excitement creates such enthusiasm for
this kind of sale RM Auctions alone
holds eight to ten options of this kind
per year a new owner might soon be
taking the wheel of Frank pets olds
Ferrari